doch was da abgeht
seit zehn jahren macht den hilfe wieder
hey leute willkommen zurück zum
megaprojekt hier gerne zusammen mit dem
kontrast luca hat wird sich ne das total
ist sich jan o
und irgendwo im hintergrund spuckt
glaube ich auch noch jeder simon rum der
simon ist nur ein bisschen dabei der ist
irgendwie halb steht die mit einem
anderen beiden steht der irgendwas weiß
gar nicht weiß gar nicht glauben dass
tod oder so was mein bruder simon ist
ich weiß auch nicht genau aber ich
lausche eurem lieblichen wort mit der
nächsten folge vielleicht auch dabei in
der nächsten folge aktiv mit aktive
partner der aktiv was da abgeht
wir lachen wir blicken massiv gestört
und spaß machen
hierbei helfen aber schon gekommen
ich weiß nicht wo sie sich befinden
diese monster ich weiß nicht wo sie sich
befinden
da ist das monster herbst gefunden das
skelett steht bei meinem fenster guckt
rein du spaß und das geld auch noch
viele auch dies vor allem auf der
monster squad eingesetzt so dumm kann
man monsters bonner sitzen wenn ich
dabei helfen du wieso hast du ne
portugal dass das surfen ich hab' ich
habe zwei brote ganz klar in der im bett
liegt auch ein komplott das bett junge
ich liegt bei niemandem häufig um auf
die minimiert des hauses glatte beine
rücken
es war schwer okay ich komme wieder
herausholen können was bleibt einem
zimmer ich kann auch selbst ausgehen
ich komme ich raus wird ist doch kein
bisschen 1000 mops von reinfeld
abgebaute mit gestalteter macht ihr mal
mit neuer geschäfte ja das geht
ich weiß es nicht nicht mehr durch
eigentlich bin ich gerade an meinem eine
place fabrik hier am abbauen damit ich
mir dann im haus bauen kann aber was
hier gerade abgeht gesundheit
was brauchst du warum ist nächsten
installieren damit ich endlich genug
energie haben
notwendig ist es so dass bei euch wieder
abgeht und bissig dahinter gerade schwer
ist heute wieder zehn jahre wieder
die bahn kommen wir einmal hier ist kein
bisschen an die kann ich manche meiner
folgen kommen jetzt gebe ja ok aber das
soll meine kumpels da ja gut ich bin was
ich denke was schenkt was kommt ja da
ist damit immer genug zu essen
ich schenke ich dir bitte ich das hier
guck mal das einst als porno von einem
schwein mit ihr auch etwas hatte ich
eigentlich gebaut das ist das hier
eigentlich all dem walliser so wo früher
dieses lava dingsbums war wo bist du
mein traum hier sieht auf jeden fall so
aus ich krieg gar nix mehr mit alter
also ich finde die wasserrutsche
eigentlich schon geheilt einfach nur ich
höre grenze wo sind meine schweine
ich weiß nicht genau wo ich meine
schweine bonner gehabt habe ich auch ein
wichtiges ponor ich weiß man könnte ja
sein skelett bonner anfang nächstes
folgt ihr seid produktion nächste folge
kommt ich musste heute jede der kann mit
seinem dinger hier ist geboren darum ich
hab hier kann man so was machen soll
ich hoffe dass mein buch des haupt ist
ist entwickelt für zauberkraft weiter
sei man ja und hilf mir was ich machen
kann
nächste folge macht so etwas wie ich
jetzt gehe ich zuerst mal eure
wasserrutsche die ist kacke also das
wirklich kranke drin was ist eigentlich
für riesenpenis bei ghom gebaut das
nicht schön das ist ein mit expert
grundstück was hat er gemacht
da ist nichts einfach
keine ahnung der macht also technisch
kram oder ja ich gehe jetzt untergrund
bei dem leichtesten alles im untergrund
verlagert glaube ich also stimmt bei dem
es überhaupt nichts mehr
die treiber den
gott hier krass aus dass ein bisschen
spannend ich weiß gar nicht was ich
machen soll um eine ganze blätter des
portfolios ich habe das problem ich habe
nicht mehr selbst singe ich kann mir
nicht mal eine neue bäume herzaubern
wieder sondern auch seinem baumhaus wie
simon master könnt ihr eure bäume
verbinden
ich meine wer hat denn eigentlich die
taverne hier gebaut dieses
gemeinschaftshaus sie habe ich geworben
wird man zusätzlich ist die stadt thun
wo ist mein solar helm auf einmal ist
alles weg mich behindert oder wo ist
mein ich muss mir neuen solar machen
dj set solar solar das erst mal schön
solarpanels baum 2 1 kg
ich hab mir jetzt gerade vor mir den
plan liegen was ich brauche in mv solar
ray und das sieht überhaupt nicht lustig
aus ich habe ja ich irgendwann auch mal
so krass the water als veraltet glaube
ich ja das heißt 64
im voraus scheiße aber da habe ich
danach nie wieder energieprobleme im
halten ok 11.56 generator moment das ist
zwar nicht so aufwendig von den ganzen
ressorts aber so elendig scheiße zu
kräften an der stelle bin ich gerade
auch rief ein teil davon
ja ich habe auch gut so da manchmal
glaube ich der main street wieder
aufbauen damit man nicht mal so ein
bisschen angst gar nicht kommt einfach
die wasserrutsche ja klar wenn dann
jemand zu dir rutscht dann geht ja gar
nicht die rutsche vor dem aus weil felix
gemeint hat er müssen sie mal bei sich
ein bisschen wegreißen über seinem
grundstück kann ich ihn jetzt aber auch
nicht verübeln schauen ich find ihn
schön den rutsche eine rutsche der
wasserrutsche und fans der batterie
brauche ich nehme noch die anderen
batterien ich will jetzt nicht alles
verbrochen für generatoren von
electronic sell gebracht habe ich auch
noch nichts mit den solar helm warten
dass das rezept für das rezept für
kilometer jolo und boxster mikrofon kann
sein
bei meinem nicht so schweers kaputt zu
machen so ich glaube ich werde mich
jetzt auch mal daran setzen dass ich mir
ein medium voltage bla bla bla mache
wir können jetzt zusammen 1 bauen oder
zwei dafür überhaupt diese überaus die
salahis ich baue die transform
einverstanden
wenn ich nicht so dafür blablabla ach
die habe ich hier so 2 davon doch der
fast gar nichts mehr
simon ja was machst du gerade mal deine
schreibt sehr cool
darf ich zugucken dachfläche was ist die
sinnvollste methode um in das wieder in
tinz verwandeln kondome am besten das
ist mal sicher dann auch nicht schwanger
werden also von kindern nein ich hatte
die im inventar irgendwie okay du bist
ja was möchtest du denn hier besuchen
kommen ich bin da wirklich produktiv ein
bisschen spaß
naja ich achte [ __ ] ich komme gar nicht
mehr runter
mein gepäck ist ja mein gott ich
realisiere gerade dringend die ganze
schweiz verfolgt die karotte land habe
ich bin jetzt einfach mal von einem
grundstück das tor an sich manchmal
funktioniert das mit vorsichtig zu wägen
den solar händler da oben steht
brauchen wir doch gar nicht was ich
deswegen gemacht habe ich lass einfach
irgendwann immer auf 30.000 auf und
enthält es eine zeit lang auch mit
solaris oder gerade wegen solarium gehen
wir nun schlafen ja gerne wieder wetten
tauschen nicht schlafen erwarten wir nur
ganz kurz da mache ich mir jetzt erstmal
alter ich muss so viele spieler wollten
schon alles machen was denkst du wenn
ich gerade da hier ach du scheiße ich
bin vom rat glaube ich zehn kilometer
oder sowas wie sich das teil hab das mit
den juli um meter diesen stoff aus dem
dutzend ziemlich jede ressource raus
machen kannst also alles schlichtweg du
brauchst du in mv solar 11,56 rief ein
viereinhalb 676 redstone 15.6 rabatte
bei dieser mini um stein aus dem man
alles machen kann
mit - dann kannst du dir sachen schön
zusammen entschieden weil er ziemlich
krass rezepte hat dir viel entgegen
bringen das produziert du schlichtweg
aus strom du hast da glaube ich 160000
strom in seine maschinen rein oder
eingeladen
daniela erzeugt genau wie genau ich das
ganze jahr über kommen mir das zeigen
woher komm du lieber zu mir rüber bis
jetzt auf kein alter fertig war okay ich
komme man vielleicht
weil ich hab es bei mir gerade noch
stehen ich hab's noch nicht abgerissen
aber einfach ist es nicht also ich habe
glaube ich zehn folgen dran gebaut bis
die maschinerie fertig hatte folgen gut
und ich brauche wahrscheinlich auch
wieder zwei folgen um das demnächst
abzureißen
ja dann schenkt mir das lieber den
ganzen kram willst du mitnehmen
besser nicht die sachen vor allem vor
allem diesem esprit kader den wir dafür
brauchst du jetzt echt teuer
letztlich das kernelement was du
brauchst und dann musste da noch kabel
stone reinstoff ganz alter bin ich
schneller willst
letztlich ist es nur energie also
durchaus energie rein
und dann gehe ich brauche erstmal energy
christel dabei ist ein diamant und acht
redstone
wo es mit social wieder hin ich hab kein
weg mehr an mir gerade 76 erstellt weil
du hast du das erstellt ich liege ja
schon nicht sein dass du einfach
außerdem verfügten stein einfach alles
machen kannst
doch man kann ich alles machen man kann
alles machen kann
es gibt eine tabelle von lachenmann kann
es stein holz kohle eisen und so gold
diamanten solche sachen die also
standard gramm im wasser landen kam aber
man kann sich vieles zum beispiel kann
man nicht daraus machen
man kann nicht ausmachen und die sache
ist ja auch was hat man davon aus dass
alles machen kann weil wenn man es so
weit ist ein spiel das man sich alles
aus diesem wetter machen kann dann
brauchen wir doch zum beispiel bin ich
jetzt da hingegangen hat mir irgendwie
10 67 meter gemacht und aus dem juli
meter kann ich mir jetzt wieder in mv
solari machen was dann wiederum
nimmersatten so denkt man dann schon
dass das geld ich bin doch brockens
katie ja ja ich habe ein kommentar
willkommen und eine dinnerparty ist im
finale meinen spielpartner von survival
games company einfach getötet
dieses brockens pay tv
jetzt aufhören jetzt mal bin ich
gestorben
so was brauche ich denn sonst noch alles
flugs wieder organisiert ist
juni heißt es komische licht was sie an
ihren komischen gehabt das frage ich
mich auch vor allem das was rangnick hat
diese komischen gelben dinger blöcke
durch solche leuchten flughafen simón
zum beispiel dabei dann dem bett steht
das auch so eine komische flimmern der
flamme als diesesmal glorias ist nico
dass du einer der ersten sachen die du
bekommst wenn du mal die erfolgs ist
einfach nur ein licht das monster und
einem grundstück sozusagen abfällt und
licht spendet das ist praktisch wie eine
fackel verkehr auf uns davon eine brücke
ab
statt fackeln zombies magisch an das
dachtest du also für diese komischen
lampen bei evonik braucht man halloween
also das wird gemacht aus restaurant la
stone und löwenzahn gelb eigentlich für
diesen ich muss jetzt betreten verboten
für alle wenn du gar nicht zuschauen bis
zu gucken wie es ist richtig was jeder
baum
die bahn richtig krasser was die was die
hier zusammen zaubern verstehen warum
der so abgeht hier jetzt gameplay war
das ne und zornig oder ja die bauern
zusammen
zweitweise zweit in so einem riesen teil
also extrem was sie da zusammen zaubern
das muss man ihnen lassen 15 sex brauche
ich noch von scheiße alter ach du
scheiße sind dass rohstoffe ich brauche
15 8 15 6 ich werde ewig dran kräften
hey was ist eigentlich einem eingriff
doch einfach sowie eine spitzhacke
unsere regel lautet alles ab eine andere
frage
20 minuten part ende und so oder ich
nehme durch auf ok da suche ich das
jetzt dazu im moment dann habe ich jetzt
schnell in fahrt also bei mir vielen
dank
süß zu sehen und bis zum nächsten mal da
ich auch endlich hat